we're two guys who i think people
probably go oh i know that guy
i know that dude yeah but they can't
kind of usually they can't
is he what who is that do you go through
that a lot where people are just kind of
staring at you looking at you pointing
at you yes uh
either they know right away or
that either you know that i went to
school with you or i
how do i know you you owe me money you
owe me money right
no i don't know that's that ain't no i
don't know you do
you owe me some money no man that ain't
me
uh i
kind of tied everything together one
time i i got in a
fight over that
what yes man
how are you getting people like crazy
because people are just
i don't know some guy was like hey
you mad tv
wait what
you mad tv ain't you
no that's i i am not
mad tv
see you changed
you changed
huh
no you from mad tv
i know you
sir i've worked on television and film i
am not from i didn't do that
and
some dude from somewhere hauled off and
and hit me in the face some guy just
came up and hit you yes
because you said you weren't on mad tv
yeah bro
yeah
was this person white no
it was a black man these were black
these were black fellas
did you fight back
uh
i i couldn't believe it okay
i couldn't believe this was there was
another
my life is flashing in front of me and i
and somebody actually was videotaping it
so
it might you know it might still be
online actually this whole oh i got to
see this no why would you want to see me
get hit no i wouldn't want to see you
did you get hurt were you hurt no i mean
i can take a punch of being that many
but i
got hit
and couldn't believe and the rage within
me
just was like
i think i said i will [ __ ] destroy
you do you know that because i i
couldn't believe
what was happening
and i just like okay i gotta remember
where i am and who i am and i don't
want to [ __ ] this guy up just because of
this but it was such a weird cheap shot
uh because of
you know mistaken identity it was just
it's just so weird bruh